Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Howdy.
Hey, y'all.
Wait.
There we go.
I was like, what's wrong with my sound?
I think.
I have phones.
We're weird.
Hello, hello.
Welcome.
In.
Time for some freaking P-Cross, baby.
Yeah!
I'm so excited.
Oh my gosh.
This game was made for me, I think.
I think so.
I'm so happy.
I'll be honest, though.
I don't know so much about Raden.
I know her from, like, some of her memes, but I don't think I've ever watched her before, so...
My brother's been playing this game.
It's awesome.
I love... First of all, I love P-Cross.
She's like a normal amount.
She's cool.
She's a big art nerd.
I can tell from the topic of this game.
It's like you go through an art museum and she tells you about it.
I hope I get to know a little bit more about her from this game.
Maybe?
I really love her design, though.
She's so pretty.
And she's got... She's the one with the mask, right?
Yeah.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Welcome to the P-Cross Cult.
Oh, I've been in the P-Cross Cult.
I've been in the P-Cross Cult.
I literally play Nonograms every day.
I was playing a Nonogram right before stream.
And then I was like...
Wait a second.
I should... I shouldn't... I should stop so that I can play on stream.
Like, not this, obviously, but my own on my phone.
I was like, wait a second.
I... I... I... I should, like, not get burnt out of playing before I play on stream.
Hahaha.
But for those who don't know what the P-Cross is or a Nonogram is...
Um...
It's...
I...
Personally...
This is my opinion.
I personally think it's way more fun than...
Sudoku.
Bleh.
I may also have been playing Nonograms a few minutes ago.
But what's so much fun about Nonograms is that it makes a picture.
So, it's way more fun to be like putting all your little points in and being like...
What could be this artwork?
It's work.
And then it's...
It's...
A leaf.
I don't know.
More like Sudoku.
Get him!
Sudoku Bros.
Sorry.
But, uh...
Yeah.
Andrey goes, thank you so much for the 20th, Captain.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Ah...
It's really nice to be rewarded with a picture.
Ah!
It's so nice.
Maybe do the tutorial for the sake of chat.
Is there a tutorial?
I actually haven't started the game yet.
Um...
Also, though...
This is made by Jupiter.
I'm covering it currently, but down here.
It's made by Jupiter.
They make like the P-Cross series.
But, this is not called P-Cross.
I think P-Cross is like a brand name, technically.
So, the general puzzle is called Nonogram.
And then, P-Cross is like a specific kind of... specific Nonogram...
Uh...
Trademark!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then, this is the same company that makes the really popular ones.
But, since this is not labeled as a P-Cross, I've just been...
They call it like a pixel dot puzzle.
So, just... just to not get...
Raden in trouble or anything, I...
Made sure to refer to it as such.
Except, well...
I did say that I like P-Cross.
But, I'm not calling this P-Cross.
I don't know.
Japanese...
Japanese companies can be so scary sometimes.
Legally distinct.
Ugh.
I don't want them to come after me.
Or her.
Not that I would think that they would see.
You know what I mean, though?
So confusing.
It's definitely not P-Cross.
Yeah, it's not P-Cross.
Hey, Minky, this is very random.
But I was re-watching the Transformers Devastation 5 and we were talking about...
The...
Rest Force.
I totally neglected to mention that one of the members is named...
Death Cobra.
And he turns into a high D!
What?!
That's crazy!
Made for me.
This PGM is so elegant, so posh.
Great for the Nonogram Goblin and Minky's brand.
I can't wait to Nonogram.
I am playing this game as I watch this stream.
I think a lot of people...
Have been playing this game.
But I feel like I've seen no...
VTubers playing this game.
Unless, like...
Hololive JP members have been playing.
I don't...
I don't know.
I'm like...
Uh...
It's P-Cross time.
I mean...
Nope.
Sorry.
It's...
PixelDot Puzzle Time.
Everybody!
Uh-oh.
I messed up.
I messed...
Bleep the wall!
I need...
I need a...
I need one of those...
Sensors.
The...
I need a delay.
So I can censor myself.
What do you do on rainy days?
I still plan on going to Kobe for the herb garden.
But the...
Forecast for this week is quite gloomy.
In Japan!
Rip on!
When it's rainy...
I go shopping.
It's probably different...
For you though.
I like go to LaForette and I just...
Or...
Window shop.
Okay.
Shall we start?
Let's see if there's a tutorial.
Cute!
I didn't know his voice!
Yes!
Uhhh...
Braden.
It's like she's really here.
I turned it off, by the way.
I can't wait to learn about art.
We'll become so cultured.
The works are divided into exhibition floors according to themes.
The works are completed by solving the pixel puzzles that then become viewable.
I'm surprised they don't call them nonogram.
Is that like not a popular term anymore?
Nonogram.
You'd think that it would be like...
It'd be so cute in Japanese too, right?
Nonogram.
You know, it'd be so cute to say.
Hmm.
Nonogram is how I've always heard it.
Right!
I feel like pixel puzzle is...
A little...
Vague.
Is your white outline new?
It's nice.
Oh!
Thank you for noticing.
I...
Actually...
Had it...
Because I had a different layout for...
My...
Where I was on the screen.
And then...
Oh, I changed it.
I did it to like kind of...
How do I say...
Hubba hubba hubba
hubba hubba...
Stick out.
Bad contrast.
I guess nonogram is a no-no.
Hahaha.
Is a no-no, graham.
Hubba hubba hubba.
Straight off the sticker street.
Oh, it reminds me of Paper Mario!
Ew.
Yeah.
You're right.
Umineko-sounding VGM.
Once you complete the artwork, a photo or illustration accompanies by Curator Rodin's explanations will appear.
Fuji-san.
Do you know the rule of...oh.
Pixel puzzles?
Okay, yeah.
We'll do the tutorial for anybody watching.
That doesn't understand.
Because otherwise, I feel like maybe...
I might start going fast, depending on how easy the beginning puzzles are, you know?
And...and...
You'll be like, what?
Why?
How is she getting this?
Mint doesn't need to hear all this.
She's a highly trained professional.
Heart Under Blade, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Yay!
Thank you so much for this, Super Chat!
I'm sorry I can't sing!
High fructose...fruc...fruc...fruc...toce...porn syrup.
Welcome to the membership, thank you!
Minta, I love you!
Thank you!
Let's watch the tutorial!
Okay.
Which control method?
Would you like to...uh, assume mouse?
Okay.
Let's explain the basic rules and concepts of Pixel Puzzle.
Wow.
Five by five.
I'm a new fan.
Do I need to watch every stream in order to be a real wisp?
Oh my gosh!
Mookie Pilled!
Oh my god!
Okay.
That's what's so fun about it.
Everything is out of order!
The timeline?
Okay, hold on.
Let me get my notes.
Okay, so...
Season three...
Is where it all begins.
But actually...
It's a fake-out.
Okay?
So...
This stream actually happened in 2008.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll have to explain it another time.
But you know, you could...
Just don't...
Just don't start...
With season 11.
But you can start anywhere else.
There we go.
Solo!
Happy birthday!
Well, I've been watching you for over a year now.
Thank you!
You need season eight before you watch season 11.
Season 11.
Season 11 is crazy.
Oh!
Okay.
It's already been a minute and a...
I suck at this game.
So much for the speed run.
Like the original run of Haruhi.
Okay.
We'll be using this puzzle as an example.
It's a bird!
Pixel puzzles are a puzzle game where you use the numbers written above and to the left as hints to fill in squares and complete an illustration.
These hints show you the number of connected squares for that row...
Orculum.
Instructions all clear starting from MGSB.
So, Ghost, thank you so much for the 515...
So, the two squares here...
Are connected to the four squares in this row.
End!
So...
Oh, it's kinda...
Here, here, here.
See, there's two here.
Three...
And one.
They cannot touch.
See, so one is here and three is here.
When there are multiple, there will always be a gap...
Between the squares represented by each number.
To reveal the hidden picture, use the hints to fill in the correct squares.
Oh, I wanted to do it.
Okay.
Once all correct squares are filled in, the puzzle is solved and a hidden picture will appear.
Let's start here.
Oh, as it's a 5x5 puzzle, this hint means the whole column should be filled in.
Have a go!
I started with Minto, the shores of Tuscany.
I was like, who's Robert?
Well done.
Next, let's look at this row.
Yes, a 3...
So...
There's at least one empty square between them.
Yeah.
Ba-bam!
What if I got it wrong?
Let's try it.
We don't need to fill in this leftover square.
Put an X.
So, right click is X.
One more year in the history books.
J-Max, thank you!
Happy...
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
You gotta watch all the made spaghetti films to truly appreciate made mint's character art.
So many birthdays.
Oh, X.
Okay.
Good.
Next, let's look at this row.
Since there's already a square filled in, there are only two ways the lines can be finished.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, we don't...
We'll put in the...
Wait, I'm gonna mess it up on purpose.
And see what happens.
Don't fill in that square!
Oh, okay.
We got it.
Why am I getting Discord messages?
Sorry.
Hold on.
Discord usually goes into streamer mode.
When I open OBS.
And recently...
It hasn't been doing that.
Streamer mode.
Stop messaging me.
Okay.
Since we know that...
So, if you don't know how PCross works...
Are you kind of...
Understanding?
Xx.
Sometimes it just stops going in the streamer mode.
Yeah, I don't know!
Oh!
It's OBS's fault!
Oh, maybe it's something with OBS that's not triggering it.
They made a change in Discord's backend that makes OBS show up as a game.
Oh, so it is Discord's fault.
It is!
It is Discord's fault then.
They had a fight.
The crows are fighting.
What you always want to do...
Or rather, what's really helpful...
With PCross is getting these...
Is getting the edges.
A.
B.
E.
Always be edging.
Two!
Oh, see?
See?
It can't be there.
So it won't fit.
So we X.
Like that.
Okay.
Watch it.
And then...
We can put them in here.
Sorry, I'm not reading it.
Now I'm going...
It's starting to get a little impatient.
Here, have a look at these examples.
If you think about it carefully...
It is always possible to find the correct pattern.
Yeah, see?
See?
So...
If there's...
This many...
And you have six...
Wait, how much is this?
Ten?
Yeah.
If you have ten...
You can fill in the middle two.
Because you know for sure they will always overlap.
And then if you have five...
You can always fill in the middle.
If it's three.
Because...
You'll know it'll always overlap.
Yeah.
Oh, I thought that said 34 for a second.
I was about to be like...
No way.
Okay.
Back to the puzzle.
So these...
This we can fill in.
See?
This is on an edge we can fill...
Where...
This is already done.
Let me finish it.
Please.
Oh, put an X in the leftover squares.
Oh.
I'm not finishing the puzzle?
Okay.
They do a good job at explaining.
Yeah, they do.
You're almost there.
Go ahead and click...
Oh.
What am I getting...
Bird!
Blue bird.
Seven minutes.
Seven minutes for a five by five.
Puzzle.
It's Twitter.
Oh.
Ripperoni.
Ittirasshan.
Oh.
She said something.
Sorry.
I was drinking my tea.
Select the input.
Let's do mouse.
Okay.
Input method for puzzles has been selected.
You can change it anytime.
Okay, cool.
Hajime.
Five.
Four.
See?
This is one.
So we put an X there.
Like that.
What is this?
It's a notebook?
A door?
A notebook?
A door.
Reading.
It's a book.
Vijai, thank you so much for the gift.
Sauce.
Oh.
You guys all saw something different.
It's a mug guys.
Would you like to listen to the commentary?
Yeah.
I'm covering it.
Wait.
I'm covering her.
Sorry, hold on.
Let me make myself a little...
Oh, she's just talking.
She's just yapping.
There we go.
I'll scoot over a little bit.
I'll go down a little bit.
Sorry, she's yapping.
Would you like to listen to the commentary again?
Like I...
I heard any of it.
No, it's okay.
We're good, I think.
Um...
Mika.
I saw you.
Superta.
Happy birthday!
Okay.
After completing the five artworks on the floor, you can enter the special exhibit located in the back.
Special exhibit features Raiden's top favorites and you can try out the puzzles.
Explan...
Ooh!
Explanations for the works in the special exhibition room are delivered with greater depth and detail.
The special exhibition rooms are available on each exhibition floor, so make sure to visit each floor and challenge those works there as well.
Do I have to do the five by fives?
Can I just...
How many are there?
I think we have to...
Oh!
Oh wait!
It gets to ten by ten so fast.
Ten by fifteen.
Oh!
Okay, wait.
Actually...
Jumps...
So...
Quickly.
So we can do it.
Easy.
Pick different...
Oh no.
We can do it.
We'll do all of them.
They get tough, I believe it.
Why is Pinto glowing today?
I have a new skincare routine.
Okay, see?
Alright.
So...
Three.
Right?
Oh wait.
I messed up.
Wait.
Don't listen to me.
One!
So there has to be a gap, right?
Like that.
One, one, one.
Gap, gap, gap.
Gap.
So...
See?
It wouldn't have been right.
Then we get into the dice and go up and go up, like that.
Thank you!
Ciao!
Oh.
Cute!
I don't see...
This weird mundo.
Yeah.
This item is the glorious Japanese flavor.
The most type of white weapon is the classic Japanese特ė.
What kind of flavor is it?
Sky and Oblivion was doing...
Alcohol flavor...
I had a sip of beer for the first time.
I tried it for the first time.
I was curious.
I was like, what's it taste like?
And... it was okay.
I was like... it was fine.
I...
It was okay.
I was told that I might not like it because it's bitter, but I drink like...
A lot of tea.
And coffee, when it's black, is bitter.
Tea is bitter.
Depending.
Oh!
It was carbonated though!
So I couldn't have... I was like, it's too carbonated.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, I can't have this.
Uh...
I can't have carbonation.
The bubbles bother you?
Yeah, the...
I don't know what it was.
I don't know what it is.
Hmm...
Uh...
It was in Japan, so...
Shiorin...
Wrong member!
This is rotten!
Ina...
This is not...
This is not even...
My VN.
Uh...
I think maybe it was like...
It was maybe like a Namabiru, but I don't know if...
That changes anything.
No, I was not sure.
Yeah.
They saw...
They saw white and black hair.
And said...
Yeah.
That's my girl.
See you like that.
Oh!
Oh, I finished that.
It's an umbrella!
That's a parasol problem.
Yoku dekimashita!
Nope!
It's a mushroom!
I feel like coffee...
I delivered a load this...
Morning, and the receiver left...
16 cases of iced coffee in my trailer.
Oh!
Omogoshi?
Yes.
Oh...
But, in the year 2024, I tasted the first time of my life.
It was so delicious.
Who translated this, I wonder?
The translation is so cute.
Okay.
We're on to the 10x10s.
Uh, view the tutorial?
No.
Um...
Oh, it automatically fills in.
That's kind of nice.
She skipped the song.
I pressed it.
It didn't play anything.
It didn't play it.
I promise.
What does C do?
I don't get it.
I don't care.
That's so...
Oh my god!
That's so handy!
Wait.
Wait, that's actually so nice.
Why that's so nice?
I've never... I've never seen...
I'm always like, one, two, three, uh.
One, two, three, uh.
Actually, I do... I do nonograms every day, but I'm actually quite slow.
I'm a... I'm a my pace kind of gal, you know.
But it's also because I... I do them...
This, but... I do them, but...
You know how I have trouble with the numbers, so it makes me...
So I mostly do it because I'm like...
It'll help me with numbers.
Same?
It's really easy also...
To, like, make a mistake, no?
And then kind of get like...
And then you're like, uh-oh, wait.
You know what I mean?
You make one mistake and it can throw off the entire puzzle.
I have no idea what's happening, but it looks fine.
It's... I think it's...
One of the much easier games to pick...
Oh, like puzzle games to pick up.
Truly.
If I can do it...
Oh, it's an eyeball, I think.
If I can do it with my...
Oh!
Gosh, that scared me.
If I can do it, I think anybody can.
You're done!
It's a...
It's a fan.
I work.
I'm completely off.
I'm completely off every time.
It's all right.
Rock語.
Uh-huh.
Wait, I'm fine.
How do I...
Oh, I wanted to press it!
If I press it, nothing happens, you guys.
Nothing happens.
See?
It's not me.
It just means there's a glossary entry.
How do I get to the glossary?
Aren't there, like, a hundred puzzles in this?
Wow.
Okay, maybe if I...
Glossary.
Eight.
Alt.
Eight?
Neither do anything.
I guess I have to wait for it to pop up.
I'm enjoying it.
Let's start.
That's right.
The music is so cute.
The music is so nice and relaxing.
Yeah, we're edging.
We're getting the edges.
Uh-huh.
See?
And then we just figured out that one.
Oh, man.
It's...
It's so easy once you get...
Once you understand.
What?
I promise.
See?
And then we just solved that whole row.
Easy peasy.
And we just solved that whole row.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Easy peasy.
Wait.
The counting is so...
One, two, three, four...
Oh, my gosh.
That's huge.
So then you can be like...
I don't wanna...
These are the ones that overlap.
It's so easy to tell.
I'm obsessed with that feature.
I think...
There are some Picross that are really...
Like the, um...
Not Picross, but Nonogram.
The... I think it's...
There's a Miku one.
There's a Miku one that punishes you...
For...
And...
Meow Tower's a little bit like this, but it's way more forgiving.
But they punish you if you, like, make mistakes.
So you, like...
Won't, like, five star...
Or the puzzle, or whatever.
It drives me insane.
Anyways, you guys...
How have you been?
I feel like...
It's been forever since I've just been able to talk...
Oops, talk to you guys...
It's a... shell.
It's a shell.
Yakuogai.
Uuuu...
Pretty good.
That's just what she has to say.
Yakuogai.
Yakuogaiの真珠草はとても綺麗で、古くからラデン細工に使われるだけでなく、磨いた貝殻をさかずきとして使っていたそうです。さらに、Yakuogaiは貝殻だけでなく、その身も人気があって奄美書島や沖縄の人たちは、食材としても重宝しているそうですよ。
What is a horn turban?
Type of snail...
Oh, I've never had that...
Let me click the exclamation button and there's more, too.
Whoa!
Oh, interesting.
I'm not gonna read all of it, though.
I'm sorry.
We did it!
Wait.
We did it?
What's...
We got the seal.
We missed you too, Minto.
Mina!
Is the game loud?
This was kind of blasting in my ears.
I was like...
Audio is okay.
I'll turn it down just a little bit.
Cause it's...
It's blasting in my ears.
Maybe I'm just quiet.
Quiet.
I solved a 40 by 30.
On this over five hours.
It was hell and I had to resort to assist, but it was worth to see a pixel version of a painting.
I've seen IRL being explained by Rod and...
Wait.
30 by...
How insane does this game get?
Oh, I see it.
40 by 30.
Why are there 50 by... 15 by 15 mixed with 40 by 30s in here?
This is...
What is this hell?
Why is it...
Five star difficulty?
Oh my god.
Long語.
Wait, I'm so curious.
Can I start at any?
Oh, it looks like it.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I wanna go in order though.
But that's nice.
Ho ho.
I wish you...
Come learn a bit more about me.
This is my game.
I've never done a skinny one like this.
It's so funny looking.
Skinny legend.
Wow.
It's so skinny.
I've never done one.
So skinny.
I've only done the square ones.
Skinny legend.
Oh, I have the counter.
And then...
Oh wait.
Oh my gosh.
This is so stinking helpful.
Instead of me just being like...
Two.
Three.
Four.
One.
Oh my gosh.
It's so...
So helpful.
Wow.
Wait.
There we go.
They're 20 by 5?
20 by 5?
How?
Wait.
Seven.
What happened?
She's calling me Sugoi, you guys.
I'm just saying.
You might...
You could be called Sugoi too.
If you played...
If you played Nonograms.
I'm just saying.
You could get some real validation here.
You can feel...
You can feel real validated.
Nonograms are for cool kids.
I promise.
They're really fun.
Barely.
I gotta pay attention.
What is this?
Maybe sake.
Sure.
It's a horse.
Can Minto call it Sugoi?
Wait.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna move over again.
Actually, I'm gonna do this.
I'm gonna...
Make my head a little bit bigger.
There we go.
Wow.
I feel like if it's rice...
It would taste yummy.
Right.
But it's fermented.
Why are you guys crying?
Oh.
You wanted me to call you Sugoi?
It's sweet and good.
Yummy.
It's smooth so you get drunk easily.
Oh, the taste is closer to water.
I want it to taste like rice.
Oh, yeah.
Rice is just a plain rice.
It's like the best flavor ever.
All my rice fans in the chat.
Yeah, rice!
Whoa, rice!
Oh...
Scoot
up.
Rice.
Ugh, my brain.
I tried to take a nap earlier.
And I think I woke up mid-rem cycle.
But I was like, I'll just go back to sleep.
Then I was like, no!
I must stay awake.
So that I can sleep tonight.
I've been trying not to nap.
It's over the jet lag.
But it's so easy to just give in to the jet lag, you know?
To just say, you know what?
The sleep schedule was never normal to begin with.
Just give up.
Your sleep schedule is never getting fixed.
No!
Actually!
So I have on my schedule...
For this week...
The, um...
Oh, whoops.
That's wrong.
The, uh...
Konami...
Has a thing for our...
What's it called?
For Silent Hill.
And for, um...
And Metal Gear.
And, um...
But I've...
And it's really early for me.
Well, it's not really early.
It's like, starts at 9am for me.
And...
I've been waking up everyday at 7am.
So, honestly...
I'm watching...
Tonight, I'll fix my schedule.
Today will be the day I'll fix my schedule.
And then I'll be like...
I can't wake up!
I'll be like...
I can't do it!
Can't wake up!
One, two, three...
Oh, I have a counter.
Yeah...
I love the counter.
I love having counter!
I'm all over the place, this puzzle.
I'm like...
I'm like all...
Oh, oh.
I'm all over the place.
I can't say I want players.
Save me!
You guys...
I've been...
I'll be honest.
I've been like wanting to do a karaoke.
Obviously, I can't.
But it just makes me so sad.
I've been so...
I've been so depressed about my voice.
I've been so depressed.
I think I probably won't be able...
Probably won't do any karaoke...
To like the end of the year.
Honestly.
Sweet.
But I also just like singing.
Okay.
You're making me so sad.
What am I missing?
Okay, here.
And this is done, I think, yeah.
It's done, it's done.
And this?
Oh, wait.
Where did I mess up?
Wait, where did I mess up?
Hold on.
I started talking and I lost track of where I am.
Oh, wait, there's a... There's a one here.
I didn't see it.
Probably not this, right?
Wait, but it's 3-1-1.
Oh, no, I messed up!
Wait, where did I mess up?
That's what I'm talking about.
It's so easy.
The bottom row.
Oh, wait.
But not here.
I messed up.
So many hours.
I even put Mario Picross in there.
Oh, yeah!
There's a Mario Picross.
This is important.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
The 3-5 row moves the 3-over one.
This way.
But then, we have the one here.
Where did I mess up?
Oh.
I got it.
Oh, I was gonna say, is it a bento?
Soba.
Oh, my gosh.
One thing I would have...
Okay.
One of my favorite meals to get at a konbini is soba noodles with inari sushi.
And I had it so many times last trip.
And... But it's not so good for you.
But I don't care.
Cold soba.
High soba.
Oh, but it's so yummy.
It's so good.
You guys!
I told you about my hotel.
And how...
My hotel was...
Doodoo garbage.
But...
Half of your healing voice is also health diet.
Oh, pssh.
Oh, inari sushi is so oily.
Oil is good for your throat, maybe.
I forgot to tell you about my flight home.
You guys.
I somehow had this flight from hell.
Coming back home.
Okay.
So it started off...
Like a little weird.
I was a middle seat, okay?
I was a middle seat in a row of three.
And...
I get to my seat.
And I sit down.
And I get comfy.
And I'm like, okay, okay.
Then the girl...
There's a...
Girl to my left.
And a guy to my right.
The girl comes first.
And...
She...
I think she was having a real bad time.
She was huffing.
And puffing.
And she...
If there was...
A piggy pig house...
She would have blown it down, I think.
She would have...
She...
She was so...
I was like...
She...
She would just kind of like...
She sat down really fast.
And she was like...
And then she would like...
She was typing really fast on her phone.
She was like...
And then...
And then she...
She would like...
Have...
Like start playing with her fingers and stuff.
Like she...
She was having a really bad time.
And...
She's... Okay, I need your opinion on this, because I asked some other people, and it was like half and half... I was always taught... That... Have you guys ever heard of the middle row arm rest etiquette?
This is how I was taught.
That if you are... An aisle seat, or a window seat... That you... Like, you give...
Or rather, the person in the middle has priority over the... The arm rest.
Middle seat gets both arm rest.
Yes!
You let the middle row have the arm rest.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I feel so validated right now.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, because I ha... I don't usually use them.
Um... Um... But this seat... I was like... I was feeling... I was feeling icky... Sticky... From the... From the humidity!
And so, I was like... I don't want to smush my arms... And have my armpits get wet.
So, I was like... Sorry, this is so TMI.
But...
I was like... Okay, well, I'm just gonna rest my arm on the arm rest.
And be comfy.
And... Um... And...
She kind of also put her arm on the arm rest.
But... That's fine.
We both could share.
I was... We were in two different spots.
And then I was like... I... Was... I had to get something out of my bag.
I had to get my headphones out of my bag.
And I got them out.
And I plugged them into the monitor.
And I put them on to watch... Watch movie.
And I put my arm back on the arm rest.
And she... She shoved it off.
She like... Aggressively went like...
Un... At me.
I was like... I was like... Oh my god.
I was like... What are you taking your anger out on me for?
I've never had that... I was like... Dang.
This is... Wow.
Okay.
Wow.
So then...
Um... The guy on my right...
Before we took off... He ended up...
Leaving his seat.
And I was... He didn't...
Come back for a long time.
But I was like... I don't know what he's doing.
Maybe he's talking with family.
Like, you know... Maybe his friends are sitting somewhere else.
And he's just talking with them before we take off.
Or... Um... Maybe he's in the bathroom.
I have no idea.
But, um...
My flight gets delayed.
And so we have to sit on the...
Plane for... A little bit while.
Because we had a...
Check engine light.
Which I've never...
The guy on the plane was just like...
Um...
We have a...
A light that came on.
And we're getting it looked at.
And then we can go.
And I was like...
Oh, okay.
I hope I don't...
Um...
Crash and have to...
You know...
Float home.
That would be so sad.
And also sad for everybody that crashes and dies.
But...
Um...
So the guy is gone.
And...
He doesn't come back.
And I was like...
Oh...
I guess maybe he switched seats.
And I didn't...
And...
But...
Because...
They kept saying...
This is a full flight.
Full flight.
And, um...
So I was like...
I don't know...
I don't know where he is.
And once we're in the air...
If he doesn't come back...
Obviously...
That's when I will...
Move over.
Because...
Free seat.
Let's go, baby.
And...
She's still huffing and puffing.
So...
Eventually when he's just like...
Yeah, we're getting this looked at.
And then we'll...
Um...
Take off.
That's when I was like...
Okay, I think I have time to...
Move seats.
And when I do...
The girl like...
Glares at me.
She goes like...
And...
Throws all of her stuff...
Into my old seat.
And like...
Throws her shoes down where...
I was sitting.
Like...
I guess she was like...
Upset that I wasn't moving...
Even though it was open.
I don't know.
I was like...
This is still...
I kind of...
Kind of territorial.
I was like...
I know it's an open seat now...
But technically...
That was my seat.
Like technically...
I paid money for that seat.
And...
It's not my...
Like...
Now I feel like I own these...
Two seats.
So...
I kind of got like...
A little upset that she was...
She was throwing her stuff...
Without asking...
Into...
Into my seat.
And...
The girls are fighting.
I was like...
People on planes are ridiculous.
I...
I don't know why she was so rude.
She was just...
She was having a bad time...
As soon as she got on...
And she kept taking it out on me.
But...
Obviously...
Once I switched seats...
I didn't really have to interact with her anymore...
Which was amazing and great.
Did you talk?
No.
I didn't say anything to her.
But...
Um...
Then...
You know...
Whatever.
Ignore her.
Um...
The...
Oh my gosh.
Probably like...
80% of...
The trip...
The flight home...
Was...
Turbulence.
Like...
And at some points...
Really, really, really bad turbulence.
Like...
Luckily...
We didn't have any...
Where we had to drop super duper far.
Like...
I've seen some videos...
Where they have to drop so fast...
That like...
Food and everything goes flying.
Luckily...
We didn't have anything like that.
But some were...
Pretty darn close.
And...
So now I'm in aisle seat, right?
Sorry, I know this flight...
Or this, uh...
This...
This is so long of an explanation.
I went from soba noodles to here.
But anyway...
Anyway...
Um...
I'm now in aisle seat.
And...
There is...
Oh...
There's...
But I'm in like the middle, right?
Like I'm in the...
So there's more seats to the right of me.
On the other side of the aisle.
And...
Some girl party.
They were like...
We're just gonna stand here.
Wow.
The plane is so turbulent.
And we're just gonna chit chat.
Right next to you.
And so...
It's so bumpy.
And they keep falling on top of me.
And their butts are in my face.
Because they're standing there talking.
Wow.
It's so turbulent.
I've never heard...
I've never heard a flight attendant do this before.
And even the captain got on the...
On the...
The intercom.
It was...
They were like...
They were begging.
They were begging these people to sit down in particular.
They were like, they were like, if you are standing, we need you to sit down.
This is not just for your safety, it is for the safety of everybody around you.
We need you to sit down right now.
And eventually they were like, oh, I guess we should go sit down now.
While they're like toppling over because of the turbulence.
Like, they could barely get back to their seat.
They're like, I guess we should go sit down now.
No shit.
No shit, you should go sit down.
I was like, if you fall on me one more time, I swear.
I swear.
And then they would like follow me and do like that laughing, like apology.
They'd be like, oh, I'm so sorry.
And then like turn around and keep talking.
Oh, they thought it was a fairground ride.
Oh, and then.
So the turbulence is fine.
I got, you know, it was a little, it was, it was a little hard to sleep, but it was okay.
And once those girls sat down for good, it was better.
Like they kept being like, they, on the intercom, they were like, we don't even have our flight attendants doing anything right now.
They are all seated.
We need you to sit down.
It helps to have a smoke in the lavatory at times like this.
And, um, yeah, they were like, they were, they were really calling them out.
And, um, uh, oh, and then there's the icing on the cake.
That little cherry on top.
It was.
Towards.
Maybe like three-fourths of the flight.
And there was a, there was a girl sitting out the window.
Little girl.
With her family.
That, with the same ones that were chit-chatting.
Three-fourths of.
She decides it's a good idea to open the window.
And for those who don't know, I've already, I, I, not too long ago.
Not too long ago, I had a flight where there was a girl who left the window on almost the entire flight.
And it was, there, it is, you are chasing the sun.
There is no darkness to be had.
And then, the kicker is on this other flight, is she would put on her, her eye mask.
And, she would put on her eye mask and go to sleep with the window open.
And this little girl, did the same, exact, thing.
This time, I had an eye mask, too.
And then, it fell on the floor when I didn't notice and I stepped on it.
And then, I couldn't use it anymore.
And that was my story of my flight.
Still usable.
Ew!
Maybe if you want to get some eye, a sty or something.
Or, you know, you want to get hep C in your eye.
You know how disgusting airports and planes are.
Pink eye.
This time fell episode as adventure.
It's true.
So true.
I prefer Pepsi.
Pink eye.
You'd get pink eye.
Blue eye.
Brown eye.
Green eye.
You'd get the whole rainbow eye.
Blue eyes by dragon.
Ma'am, this is the soba exhibit.
She's waiting so patiently.
To say the commentary.
Okay.
That was my story.
Let's listen to about soba noodles.
And this is the second one.
The second one is the second one and the second one is the second one!
Please try it with salt and salt.
Obviously, I don't eat with... with a... with a... I almost called this guacamole.
Japanese guacamole.
The wasabi.
But I love it with the little onions.
That's the spicy guacamole.
The danger guac.
I live life on the edge.
She's losing it.
Recalling that plane story really just did me, huh?
But yeah...
Soba noodles with inari sushi.
Perfect combi.
So, so good.
Okay, we're back.
We're locked in.
15 by 15, baby.
Oh, so many numbers.
So many numbers.
Why are some of these blue?
I just noticed.
Why are some of them blue when you start?
Huh?
Hmm...
One they can work on.
Ah!
I see.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm counting?
Huh?
I don't know.
Small hints.
That's so fancy.
It's nice.
But yeah.
You guys have any...
Any horror story?
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I didn't even realize I could finish this.
Hahaha.
I'm shilly.
Any plain horror stories?
I guess when you fly...
I've...
You know, I've...
Especially been flying so much.
I'm obviously gonna have...
A lot of...
Hit and...
Misses.
I don't know.
Minesweep with...
But rotten.
It's nonogram!
Put some respect in it's name!
Yattou!
I repress my airplane trauma.
That's so true.
It's like...
You know...
It's...
It's like...
The flights are long.
But ultimately...
Unless I'm like...
Actively in pain or something...
It's...
Forgettable.
You know what I mean?
Like...
It's...
It's like...
Just an inconvenience.
And I go about...
Go...
Continue my afterlife.
One time I was flying with...
Wait.
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, I think I actually...
Lowered the volume.
Or something.
May takee, may takee...
Guru, guru, guru, guru.
Oh, she just did the song.
Why?
We once had kids...
That would kick our seats...
So my dad threatened to kick their asses.
May takee, may takee...
Guru, guru, guru, guru.
Guru, guru, guru.
May takee, may takee...
Guru, guru, guru, guru.
She's on the tune!
I love the feeling of takeoff and turbulence.
Since, I always fall asleep.
I flew for the first time to see the Phantom Thief concert.
It went really well, thanks considered.
Fly enough times and...
That will definitely change.
Nah.
Wait, seven.
But also, I guess it depends on some airlines as well.
Like if you go with like...
The US has some really like...
Budget ones that are...
I've never...
I've never tried them.
But I've only heard...
Horror stories of them.
Wait.
How did I...
How did I mess this up?
Wait.
I'm not locked in at all.
Wait, wait, wait.
Dull.
Frontier and Spirit.
Oh.
Yeah, I've heard this.
But I feel like Spirit Airlines would be perfect for me.
Frontier lost my luggage for a while...
And broke for the zippers.
No.
That's so bad.
Flying to New Orleans tomorrow...
To go work in the Pokemon International Championship.
Giving me a lot of good ideas...
For things to do...
To give my fellow passengers stories for the hitter.
Your evil skeleton dog.
I'm gambling on Southwest.
I feel like Southwest, I've heard, is not so bad.
No?
Okay, I have to figure out...
Where did I mess up?
Where did it all go wrong?
I'm...
I'm so early in the puzzle, I've already messed up.
How?
It has to be here.
But then the seven...
What did I do?
I feel like I'm...
Oh, wait.
Can I start over?
Can I redo?
I'm locked in.
Just wait.
Restart.
Okay, we restart.
First...
PyroWog!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Japan Airlines.
Tokyo to LAX.
Yeah...
Japan Airlines, I've heard, is really good.
I gotta lock in.
Making a phantom thief.
Love the last cup of coffee.
I'll be a house super rendered YouTuber.
Oh...
Yeah!
I have to upload mine.
Yeah...
I don't wanna...
I'll do that.
Eventually.
Wait, this one we can do the whole thing, no?
Yes.
You're...
Oh, oops.
Oh...
Oh, wait, that was right.
Three...
Five...
Maybe I misread these up here.
Why does it seem different already?
Something feels off.
Did I misread?
Maybe I misread.
Count!
Tokyo has to pay you her collab fee for...
Somehow my flight to Baltimore ended up as...
Eight hours next to a guy who constantly tried to put his arms...
Over the armrests.
Elbowed me when there was turbulence and...
Religious texts out loud the whole flight!
Maybe...
I
feel like...
I...
I feel like...
Some...
Point that...
At what...
At what point...
Do you call...
A flight attendant?
Um...
You know...
At what point is it...
Because I don't want to ever feel like I'm a Karen, you know?
But at what point does it feel like it's appropriate to be like...
Okay, this is not...
This is not behavior that...
That's...
That's my personal hell.
Phoebe!
Hello, hello, welcome here!
I was watching you earlier with the comfy direct!
I was watching...
I didn't say anything...
But I was watching...
Thanks for the raid!
Thank you, SF2!
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Phoebe!
Hi for reading!
Thank you, guys!
Ducky!
Thanks for the five gifted...
Speck!
Oh, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Fiverrack!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Twarko!
10 out of 10...
10 out of 10 times I've asked someone on a plane to stop doing something...
They've done it...
Most people are somewhat reasonable...
Yeah.
Bye.
It's to avoid the conflict.
Oh.
Wait, I missed one.
Wait.
Did I say Duargo?
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm having to... Oh, it's rewinding.
I was wondering what it was doing.
That's crazy.
Oh, sorry.
It's one of those games where if I click out... Oh, my gosh.
Yoshi, thank you.
Flight was delayed five more hours.
Oh, my gosh.
Mario, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Rami, thank you for the gifted.
Thank you.
Okay.
Lady fell asleep on my shoulder for half a flight.
When she woke up, she just carried on like nothing happened.
She's probably embarrassed, no?
There's rewinding in this game?
Yes, there is.
If you use the scroll wheel.
You see down here?
You can like... It's basically an undo button.
Maybe I should have done that instead of... Okay, wait.
I gotta lock in.
Two... Wait.
Now, let me continue the game.
Two...
One, two, three, four.
Yeah.
That has to be.
Hum hum.
That!
That's what I had before.
I like the little...
Which it does.
Mm-hmm.
Now, the reason...
You're probably like...
You can do something here, Minto.
With...
What we don't know...
As you can see...
So...
Okay, so...
In...
In P-Cross, you never want to assume...
You never want to assume like...
Oh, this is one...
And then two...
And two.
You know?
It could be...
This is two...
Two, two...
And the one is in here.
You know?
So that's why...
I'm kind of...
Leaving it...
Open.
So...
It's one of those types of...
You can't be so hasty sometimes.
That's not how that works.
It is?
What do you mean?
It's 100% how that works.
It's...
Looking forward to Karen...
Vinto...
Helmet...
Hair reveal.
I don't get it.
That's how it works.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Rami, thank you.
Bob cut.
Oh, the Karen!
Oh, right.
Because they always have like...
Okay.
You know...
If Karen's dyed their hair black...
It would just be...
A scene...
Emo kid cut.
Think about it.
If the hair...
Was a little less swept...
And a little more like...
In their eyes...
It would not.
Yes, it would!
It would!
What is a Karen haircut?
It's like...
Okay, I'm gonna use Raden.
I'm sorry.
As an example.
Just so I can show.
The hair...
Sweeps...
And then it's like short here.
Kind of like how she has her Hime cut.
And then it's like...
Spiky short on the back.
Oh!
She's...
She's showing off.
It's like...
Or it can be flat.
But sometimes they're poofy.
Ba-Baaam.
Okay.
Let's see...
And then...
Oh!
Here we have one...
These light up.
But they make me nervous.
Why do they light up?
Like they know something, I don't.
What do you know?
Oh, I just noticed the one up here.
Oh, I'm so silly.
I didn't even notice I had the one up there.
Okay.
Relaxing.
That is pretty relaxing.
I like the soundtrack for the puzzle time.
It feels like...
Like a... like a...
RPG.
You're on a farm.
Like a...
Story of Seasons type.
Like a hometown.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like a town music.
Yeah, Harvest Moon.
Harvest Moon.
That's what I was thinking.
I said Story of Seasons, but Harvest Moon.
It's like you read my mind.
I'm not locked in.
Okay, hold on.
No...
What else can I do?
Oh wait, I can get rid of that.
What can I do?
You're right!
Minto, did you ever get your yogurt?
Oh my gosh, I did!
But it was like...
I'm not gonna lie.
It was kind of mid.
Oh, you see?
We figured it out.
It wasn't these two at all.
It was this.
And then we can solve for...
You.
We can solve.
And I didn't mess up this time.
Yeah, it was pretty mid.
You can do the seven in the second row.
Midori, I did it.
Thank you.
Oh, I did it.
We did it.
We did it, Reddit.
What was the first ever we did it, Reddit?
I only say it for the meme, but I actually don't think I know.
When was the first time ever that they said we did it, Reddit?
What's the story?
Give me the internet history.
Oh, it's not great.
Oh.
It's a dark story.
It was a bummer.
Okay, ignore it.
I'm gonna undo.
Forget that I ever asked.
Forget I asked, actually.
Okay, never mind.
Anyway.
I apologize.
We did it, SpongeBob.
Okay.
One.
What do you mean we can...
Okay.
Oh, because we can fill in that.
Wow, it really...
Three, four.
It really does give in the hint.
Wait.
That's wrong.
There we go.
Sometimes too many numbers.
I wonder what the picture is.
I'm trying... It kind of looks like Uboa to me.
Kind of looks like Uboa.
I don't think it is, but...
Could be.
Who knows?
You never know with a Peacross.
It's me, actually.
The eyes?
And the nose?
And the mouth?
It's another mushroom.
Don't say that.
I don't think it is.
What is it?
I can't tell.
I can't tell at all.
It's definitely a face though, no?
The eyes?
And the nose?
And the mouth?
The mouth?
Well, it's not Henohe no mohezi.
A mask?
That's right.
Huge of real.
Oh, it's smiling.
Definitely not Henohe no mohezi.
Oh, it's her mask!
No mean.
It's the nose mask!
Oh...
Wow...
Cute!
Oh, special artworks room soon.
Wait, I feel like we could go now.
No, we'll do this one.
Challenge.
Whoa, whoa.
So many blue.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
That is a fun fact.
That's a rock fact.
Hold on, let's do this one first.
Three...
Seven, yep, okay.
Two, three, four...
There we go.
And same on the other side.
And here.
I don't know.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I like when a 15x15 peak cross has a 3-7-3-roll.
I like when she reassures me.
Actually, I don't even know if she knows I'm right.
So when she does the humuhumuhum, I wonder if I'm wrong.
Because I'm like...
Are they supposed to be like...
Thank you.
Wait, um...
Yeah.
Wait, it's just like the other side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe she has no idea either.
Maybe that's why I'm solving these.
Has she ever...
For anybody...
Any of Daiden fans...
Has she ever expressed...
Interest in...
In...
The...
In the...
Oh, wait!
Smash!
It's the Smash logo!
Raden is Smash!
She's good for Smash!
She got her invitation!
New challenger!
Nice!
And...
Three...
Two...
Wait, how...
What do you mean...
Oh, that...
I was like, what do you mean I can do something else here?
Oh, I didn't even notice the 373 here!
Hehehehe...
Hmm...
What could it be?
It's totally symmetrical mostly...
Like, it's...
Pretty symmetrical so far.
It's pretty...
Actually, I...
I didn't even take a good look at this...
To see if the whole thing is symmetrical or not.
Ha ha ha ha ha...
Not enta...
ENA-E-E-ER...
L-l-l-l-l-l-l...
Taruhodo!
Doesn't seem...
Entirely symmetrical...
Hmmmm...
Hmm...
Close, but not quite...
Yeah...
Oh yeah...
See?
You can even see...
Hmm...
I'll wait...
Let's see...
Yatta!
I like Peek.
I like it normal, man.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Undo.
Yeah.
Wait, show puzzle after we won.
Wait, what does that mean?
Yes?
Peek, thank you so much for the gifted!
Yatagarozu!
Wait, can I click yes?
Oh, okay.
Oh,
oh!
Wait, I think it's the...
The bird logo?
Oh, yeah, it's the logo.
Yatagarozu.
It only tells me the thing in the glossary, but it's here.
That could be a really good name for the club.
The three-legged crow.
I'm a Tarasu!
Oh, that's where...
That's right, that's right.
You can go to the shrine for Amaterasu.
It's in Ise.
Ise Jingu.
It's really, really nice there.
I suggest it very much.
Yeah, it's kind of far.
It's a little past Nagoya.
But...
I really...
It's also like a big town.
And it's all very traditional Japanese...
Flinky.
Feeling.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Utsuho.
Wait, is this what she is?
Yatagarasu?
Is she Yatagarasu?
Utsuho is...
She is?
I never knew.
Wait, where's her third leg?
The sun on her chest.
I'm looking this up.
Utsu...
Toho.
The thing on her chest is always, I thought, like an eyeball thingy.
There's no bird there.
Is it supposed to be a...
I always thought her arm was like that just because...
She's radioactive.
Radioactive.
Sorry.
Toho is a normal crow who ate...
Yatagarasu.
I'm me learning Toho lore in this very moment.
I didn't know that.
You guys, never...
Be ashamed of what you don't know.
Because then you learn something new.
You know?
You can say I'm a fan of something.
And still not know every single thing about it.
It'll be my birthday on Wednesday since you won't be streaming.
Can I trouble you with a happy birthday?
Ruv!
Happy birthday!
Early!
My absolute favorite is displayed in the room at the...
She's trying to get me into the back rooms.
Let's go.
I've still got a long way to go myself.
What does that mean?
Which square should we paint first?
All of them.
End.
Sorry.
I said that kind of loud.
Wow.
Easy.
Easy, easy, easy.
Unlock them.
Not really.
I'm actually quite slow with these, I feel.
I'm actually quite slow.
Because I did make mistakes.
You know?
So easy to make a mistake.
I shouldn't be shamed of what I don't know.
I'd like to learn...
Oh.
Well, I'd like to learn what mint stars...
Fee.
Fwer.
Free, fi, foll, foam.
What game is that from again?
What game is that happening again?
Oh, oh gosh.
Duh.
What's it called?
The Summer Games Fest.
Call of Duty!
That's right.
The Summer Games Fest, when they announced the new Resident Evil, they played us.
Did you guys watch that?
When they did the announcement, I was just like, thanks for supporting Resident Evil.
We'll have some things in the future.
And I was like, I was so... I was like, that's it?
Really?
Everybody else was too, right?
We got played so hard.
They actually... They actually did such a good job of getting everybody.
It's pretty funny.
And then, but when they showed RE9, and I was like... I first saw it.
I didn't think it was.
...because it looked too good.
But part of me wished it was a new David Cage game.
I was like...
I saw some people that were saying that they could recognize the engine.
...uh, like the character's hairs...
...uh...
...with the engine and everything for it...
...but of course, once I saw the statue and saw the police station...
...I was like, oh, shoot.
Guys, oh, Raccoon City.
When it was still...
...I was like...
...I was like, come on!
Give me...
Give me the next David Cage.
I'm ready for it.
Do not.
Oh, come on.
I want...
Can't...
I just have, like, a guilty pleasure?
They're so bad.
They're so funny, you guys.
Please.
Let me have this.
They're peak trash.
I know.
I love it.
But...
But alas...
It was...
...not that.
I think people...
I think people would have given up on the gaming industry.
I think people would have been like, I'll never...
I'll never trust again.
If...
It would have been great, though.
Please do tell what cage games have you played.
I played...
Detroit...
Become a human.
I played...
Uh...
Heavy Rain?
Is that David Cage?
Wait, hold on.
Let me look up David Cage.
Yes.
Oh, yeah!
Because it's the Origami Killer.
Sure!
Sure.
Um...
And that's it.
I think.
Wait!
No, wait!
Those are the only two I've done?
Well, he's only done one...
One...
One, two, three, four, five.
I've played two of that.
Two of them.
Beyond Two Souls.
Yeah, I haven't played that one.
I have not played that one.
Sounds like you have a backlog.
I have to play through all of them to...
To unlock the new game.
The next...
The next one.
He'll release a new one as soon as I play it.
As soon as I play any more of them.
When you guys were saying the Beyond Two Souls, I'll be honest.
I thought you were talking about that.
There's that new game that came out...
Like, I think...
This year or early last year?
Or late last year?
That was like the...
Two-player game.
That's kind of like...
It takes two, but...
No, I'm pretty sure it came out this year.
And you like play as the ladies that...
Lose their imagination or whatever.
Split fiction.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I was thinking.
You guys are talking.
I was like...
I was about to be like...
He...
He made that.
Split fiction.
Imagine a Picross game for Mint.
Mintocross.
It would be awesome.
The Wumie.
The Holy Wumie, not Wumie.
Thank you for the peek.
Yeah, it would be awesome, right?
Maybe...
Maybe next game I do...
Will be a Picross.
Picross style.
A dot puzzle.
Dot puzzle game.
Two.
Four.
Six.
Hey, who do we appreciate?
What would the pictures be, though?
I don't know.
Oh, we got big, big Raden.
No!
I've been to a couple of落語...
...performances.
The lakugo anime... Is that the one that has that really catchy song?
Why are you laughing?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, that's right.
Oh.
Omicron.
Well, do you like which ones you like?
If you like which ones, you will be happy to see which ones you like.
She's so cute.
I'm a Cron.
It's David Cage's first game and he possessed people to further the plot.
It also has David Bowie.
Why would you want her to suffer?
Yeah, the Joshi Roku song is so...
It's so catchy.
Look how cute she is.
So cute.
We got the special art.
Shooting on her.
Omicron will drive you insane.
Look how cute she is looking at it.
Oh.
She looked at me.
I guess we move on to the...
Next area?
How do I do that?
I guess from here.
Yeah.
Oh, it's all like...
It's all things...
I didn't even notice that...
The topic was her.
Western paintings.
10 by 20.
40 by 30 already?
At level 14?
Am I ready?
Oh my gosh.
It's so ugly.
I like how it's like...
You can do these ones.
It's so ugly.
Easy peasy.
Yeah.
And then...
Right?
I have a counter.
And these are all...
These all should be six.
Yeah.
Six, six.
Six, six, six.
Stay open.
Eight, eight.
Yattou!
No music?
The difficulty spikes pretty early in the game.
I like that though.
Because...
Oh, wait.
Did I...
Miss Kiao?
No.
Okay.
We're good, we're good.
I like...
I like that...
This is made...
Kind of more for...
P-Cross fans.
Rather than...
Because sometimes...
You know, I love Meow Tower.
That's an app...
That I play every day.
For...
For nonograms.
But it's...
It's really, really easy.
It's really, really, really easy.
Oh, 13.
Wow.
Wait, is this 13?
It is.
Silly minto.
What am I selling for?
What?
We messed up.
Where did I mess up at?
The first column.
Let's restart.
Wait.
Actually, wait.
Yeah, let's restart.
All right, let me rewind.
Let's see where I move.
Maitake, maitake.
Guru, guru, guru, guru.
What's it a new bee?
Why did I think that was a thing?
Why did I do that?
Okay.
There we go.
Wow, I really messed that one apart.
That's why you called me silly.
Surely not.
Where am I?
You're at a phantom channel.
You're at the museum.
We're learning art today.
We're becoming really educated and cultured and...
We're becoming...
We're becoming artists.
I went to our museum not too long ago, actually.
Um, I went to a Van Gogh exhibit.
And you know what I learned about that guy?
That guy is the original weeaboo.
He used to draw...
He used to...
We wish that...
Like, he were Japanese.
And he would like...
He would like...
Draw...
Like...
Yeah, he was obsessed with Japan.
He was kind of...
Kind of crazy.
Japanese art was a big trend in Europe then.
Yeah, it was crazy.
When I saw that, I was like...
Wow.
He's just like me.
For real, for real.
I don't think I should cut off my ears.
Ear?
Ear.
I can't...
Okay, so what I've done basically is...
Because I've completed down here...
I've completely written off that part of the map.
And I was just like...
Wait a second.
I messed up.
I don't have enough for six.
I've completely...
Just written that off.
Only one ear for art powers.
Oh my god.
That sounds like...
If Austin Powers wanted to be...
Um...
Wanted to be...
Van Gogh...
He could be...
Artin Powers.
Mako, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Don't minus two of me.
You guys all know what to do.
No, it was good.
Why couldn't the artist drive his car?
He didn't have the Monet to...
De...
Degas to make the van go.
My...
Minus two.
You guys all know what to do.
When...
If you're new to this channel...
Uh oh.
Wait, I messed up.
Oh, just kidding.
I didn't mess up.
I'm actually a genius.
Um...
When you...
Yeah, boo!
See?
Boo!
I knew you liked it.
Stop being so tsundere.
Wait.
Oh.
What is this?
Oh wait, this...
It's the Mona Lisa!
It's the Mona Lisa, it's the Mona Lisa.
I was like, what's the topic?
Western art.
Mona Lisa.
It looks like the Minecraft version of her.
Look at that nose.
Jump scared by the real Mona Lisa.
Wait, no, no.
Oh, what?
What are you saying to me?
What does this mean?
S-F-S-Fumato.
This really looks like the Minecraft version, though, doesn't it?
Because it's like the villager nose.
I thought she was telling me to S-TF you.
You already know the monster Leonardo DaVinci's Mona Lisa, right?
Oh, that's right.
DaVinci's Mona Lisa's character.
S-Fumato.
And we can also add the other characters to the other characters.
Wow, I feel like I'm actually learning so much...
...from this note.
I feel like I'm actually learning so much.
This one, you guys, is three stars.
Will we be okay?
I did it!
Oh wait, wrong one.
There we go.
We need to game in?
Where?
That's great!
That's right!
What is this?
Seven.
Easy.
Yeah.
It's hard.
It's
good!
It's cool!
What is it?
We're losing her.
I'm already gone.
Here.
Sometimes it's hard to count.
Sometimes counting do be hard though.
Oh, we can finish this one.
Finish that one.
That one.
She's locked in.
I'm locked in.
Yeah.
Sometimes I just go into the trance.
It's the... it's the... nonogram trance.
There we go.
Yattou.
Yep.
I see.
We did it!
What is that?
Spooky time!
I don't think I recognize this one.
Oh.
She look... yeah, she look mad.
One thing I do like watching is...
Is like art...
Not art commentary.
Art dissection videos.
And like when they're just like...
As you can see, she's wearing a glove.
That means she's...
She's only wearing one glove.
She's held back by society.
And you can see that there's a...
There's a pearl on the ground.
Which...
That indicates...
That means that...
It symbolizes...
Symbolizes...
Her want to escape.
Symbolism analysis.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
FNAF lore, but with paintings.
I like...
I like watching those.
They're pretty fascinating.
Especially when they're like...
Paintings that are...
Kind of based off of real...
Events.
Like...
Or like stories.
So...
There's one...
I can't remember what it's called right now.
Maybe if I describe it...
Somebody will know.
But um...
There's one where it's like...
Family dinner.
Or family...
Food time.
And...
The story is that...
The brothers are about to murder...
Their sister's husband.
They're about to behead him.
Because...
Some...
Some renaissance nonsense.
You know?
They're beheading everybody back then.
But...
The painting is them at...
At the dinner table together.
And um...
Uh...
The way that they're like...
Looking at him...
Oh gosh...
Oh...
Let me see if I can find it.
Just a normal day.
I wonder if I could put in context clues.
Painting?
If I see the painting...
I'll...
Oh no...
I'm just getting beheadings now.
Oh no.
I'm just getting paintings and beheadings now.
I think I messed up.
Oh my gosh though.
I also really love this painting.
The one of Lady Jane Grey.
Ugh!
Oh my gosh.
It's so...
Hauntingly beautiful.
If you've never seen it before.
It's also...
Based on a real person.
Who...
She...
Kind of got used...
Not kind of.
She got used by her family.
And she was like...
She was like...
What was it?
Sorry.
I'm gonna get the history wrong.
Cause...
Right now my brain.
But she...
She was like...
Back in...
Hold on.
Let me just read it.
So I don't get it wrong.
Lady...
Whoa.
What is that?
That's crazy.
Ooh!
Lady...
Jane Grey.
Yeah, she was the Queen of England for like three weeks.
Yeah, for like a super short amount of time.
And...
Because like...
Her family was...
Like...
Feuding and everything.
About who was going to become...
The...
The rulers.
And...
Uh...
She was like...
Just a kid.
And they...
They...
They executed her.
Because she was...
She was the Queen.
But...
It was like so messed up.
They used her.
So crazy.
The nine days queen.
Not...
I remember it was like a couple days.
Like it was ridiculous.
Back in 15...
54.
She was a scapegoat.
So sad.
That's crazy.
Gosh.
They were just beheading everybody back then, huh?
The good...
The good old days.
You know what?
We should have...
More black playing.
Eliza and Jonathan, I said Isabella by...
Let me see.
Thank you.
Oh.
My.
God.
That's...
The painting I was talking about.
Isabella by...
Melaius.
Melaius?
Yeah.
That's the one I was talking about.
Where they're at the dinner table.
And they're like glaring at the husband.
And...
He's gonna die.
And everybody at the table knows it.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
That's the one.
And they're like...
He's like pointing at him with his toes.
Melaius.
Oh, maybe.
Ah.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
The analysis on this painting is so fascinating.
Anyway.
Sorry.
Let's listen to the commentary about this one that I have no idea about.
Oh.
It's Da Vinki.
It's like a good angle.
I feel.
Oh.
It's like a good angle.
I feel.
Oh.
Dovinki bros know Fuomoku, so maybe...
That's so crazy.
They're actually so funny.
The... Dovinki bros...
I don't remember what their names are, but they're actually so funny.
I like their videos.
Does it ever occur to you, Vinto, that Dovinki bros have their own individual names?
Yeah, it's...
Patrick and...
Uh...
I don't remember the other guy's name.
Boros twins!
I know, because what their Riz names is Patriz and...
Uh...
The other guy...
I can't remember his Riz name.
Chris?
I don't remember.
Is it Chris?
Chris?
Oh yeah, because it was Chris and Patriz!
What's your Riz name?
Minto.
Got an interview this week.
Wow!
And he made magic for something like that.
Let me go consult the handbook in the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Guys,
I'm gonna be honest.
My voice is...
Starting to feel a little strained.
So...
I think I can do one more puzzle, and then I will...
Um...
I will...
Uh...
Call it there, probably.
I'm sorry.
Oh, whoops.
Not bad.
There we go.
So I think I can do one more puzzle.
One more.
Unless it's really easy.
15 by 15.
Okay, let's try...
Let's try the 40 by 30.
Let's try a 40 by 30.
Um...
Oh!
For your...
Micmac.
For your interview.
Nei nei.
Just...
Uh...
You...
Should...
Mention the maid.
This is my...
This is my first ever full...
Okay...
Wait...
Uh...
When I played Nancy Drew...
If anybody watched that...
Here...
I said that...
One of the ones that I did...
Was the largest that I have done.
This is the one that took me 5 hours.
I can't remember if it was 20 by 20...
Or 25 by 25...
Start...
Let's see...
We're gonna be relying on the counter here.
A lot.
22.
It was 25 by 25.
25 by 25.
So this would be the biggest one that I'll ever challenge.
I'm scared.
I don't even know...
Where...
How are these possible?
These ones...
Okay...
Three...
Ten...
One...
Three...
Like that...
Middle click or holding V as a pencil.
Oh...
Interesting...
I didn't realize that...
Thank you...
I don't know...
When I would use that though...
Hmm...
So this is 10...
10...
Wow...
It really is 40...
So 19 would be almost half...
No...
Oh yeah...
So...
Let's see...
Hold on...
19 would be almost...
Half...
So I feel like we can...
Go to like here...
Right...
I'm just guessing...
Maybe I messed that up...
Let's...
Get rid of it...
Okay, hold on...
2...
1...
3...
13...
14...
15...
16...
19...
Like that...
Holy...
This is...
Intimidating Phil...
Thank you so much for the fun...
Good to thank you...
For people who came in...
A little later...
And are kind of like...
How do you play this game?
I don't understand it at all...
At the very beginning of the stream...
Uh...
We went through the tutorial...
So if you're like...
I...
I don't understand the rules...
But I...
I'm curious...
You can watch that...
And uh...
It'll probably help you a little bit...
2...
1...
3... 4...
2...
3...
4...
5...
6...
Oh wait...
Let's put that...
That's where 6 is...
Okay...
So 3...
1...
10...
2...
3...
4...
5...
6...
Dang...
Wow...
It's cute...
What?
Okay...
1...
2...
3...
4...
1...
2...
3...
4...
5...
6...
1...
10...
Wow...
I can only fill that one in...
This is kind of crazy...
This is kind of...
Cookie...
1...
Now I'm understanding the point of this...
So 5...
Yeah...
Missed you...
Oh...
There has to be...
That...
It is 11...
Yo, yo, yo... To 10.
Right?
Wait.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
And... 9.
I don't wanna... Wait.
Wait.
Yes.
Okay, okay.
Wait, how is this... 10?
But this is not... Ah!
Because it's not 10.
It's not 11.
Okay.
We're fine.
One down too.
And keep going down.
Keep going down.
We can still do stuff there.
Okay, we can still do stuff here.
Interesting.
I know how to play this, and this one is pretty daunting.
Yeah.
Luckily, there's a lot of pretty big numbers.
I believe in us.
Team!
Okay, so this is...
Currently 9.
Right.
It has to be like that.
Wait, so...
Let's say this is 10.
Skip.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
Ah!
Wait.
So then...
That one is not.
That one can't be.
Because...
The 9 there.
I think you can do that entire leftmost column that's blue.
This one?
Oh, I don't...
Think so.
Can't you?
1...
Wait...
8...
1, 2, 3...
I don't think so.
Hold on, wait a minute.
Wait...
I can't...
It's hard keeping track of...
Okay, so that's 12.
Yes.
What I'm so interested in is...
How this is going to look.
Because it's so huge.
It's going to be so intricate.
Oh gosh.
It's going to look so good.
I'm so excited.
Oh my gosh.
It's going to look...
It's going to look exactly like the painting.
It's going to be so detailed.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, pretend this is 7.
1...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8.
How can I still do more here?
Are you kidding me?
Oh.
Because I only went to 8.
I did.
Oopsie.
Calling it great wave of Kanagawa.
Good guess.
Throw in your bets, everybody.
Throw in your bets.
Throw in your...
Throw in your butts?
Throw in your butts.
1, 2, 1, space.
2, space.
3, space.
6, space.
1, space.
2, space.
3, space.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Wait, oh yes, so then this has to be here.
Wait, no, this is, it can't be a great wave.
It has to be a western painting.
It's a western painting, that's what the theme is.
What could it be?
Starry night?
The great western wave.
Great wave with a cowboy hat.
I lost it.
Wait.
Oh, that was satisfying.
And then we can probably...
19.
Ah... We can do this.
11.
Yeah.
We can do that.
Hold on, hold on.
Hit me, hit me, hit me.
This one's tricky, you guys.
This one's a lot.
This one's so much.
The scream?
What's that guy's name?
Munch Crunch?
Bad apple.
I see Remu?
Actually, no.
This is the moon and Marisa is flying towards it.
It says we can do this one too.
Let's see.
19.
I can't do, like, the division math, you know?
That's the part that gets me.
Or, like, you know, like...
Oh.
Okay.
I have to, like, be like, okay, can I do seven here?
And then...
Five.
No, you can't.
Okay, so the six and seven have to be...
Okay, so...
Six goes to here.
Seven goes to here.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Eye fatigue.
Yeah.
And then...
Space.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
I don't know.
I think...
I think, I think.
And then five...
Purashur.
Six.
Okay, so then...
One, two...
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay.
Paying my rent to the smelly ghost maid.
Thank you.
I don't understand how this works.
Like, first instance, the 19 at the bottom.
Why couldn't that have been at the far right?
Good question, CS Dragon.
So, it's always going to be...
In this...
Order that you see.
So it's going to be 11...
And then...
Followed by 1.
Followed by 2.
So because the 19 is on the far left...
It had to be somewhere...
In the first...
As the first part of the...
Of the sequence.
Hmm.
Essentially.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And there's always one...
Minimum...
One space between each number.
Exactly.
So that's why...
For like...
We have 19 here.
That's why we can immediately put a little space...
Next to it.
Because...
We know that there will...
100%.
Be a space.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
This one is so hard.
They're like...
This one's lit up.
But I'm like...
How?
Maybe...
Maybe because it has to be 10 here.
Oh.
That was exactly it.
Okay.
We're running out of blue...
Rows and columns here.
Okay.
I'm just gonna start doing...
You know what?
I said...
I don't know when I'm ever gonna use the...
The little middle click.
Here I go.
Okay.
So now...
We're doing it like this.
Actually...
No, I'm not even gonna put those.
I'm just gonna pretend.
All right.
2.
1.
Let's just...
That's temporary.
Oh, wait.
No.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
2.
Oh, wait.
I just realized.
I think it definitely has to do with something with the 7.
So...
Oh.
1.
Space.
I don't know.
Nope.
2.
Space.
I should have marked where the 7 was before, but that's okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Okay.
We were pretending this was the 1.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
I think it has to be like that.
Pretty sure the blue means you can deduct where the squares go without needing to guess.
Yes.
It does.
In theory, I guess.
This one...
I'm like, how?
Unless...
Okay, let's see.
1...
Wait.
Alright, here.
We'll do it.
Opposite.
1...
Space.
2...
Holy cow.
Worse.
Imagine this 40 by 30 is your first no-no-gram ever.
I think it'd be impossible, though.
I think you would...
You would not.
I don't think you could.
But then again, never say never.
Oh.
Wait.
That's not what I meant to do.
See.
Oh.
Gosh.
Oh, golly.
Okay.
This...
This row confuses me.
What do you know that I don't know?
This one took me two hours.
It might take us a while.
Me saying my throat is starting to feel strained.
But actually, I got more tea and it's starting to feel a lot better.
How much more difficult did they get?
Ah, this is...
This is...
A 5 out of 5 stars difficulty, so...
I think this is as difficult as it gets.
Alright, let's see.
If I do 3...
Space.
1, 2, 3, 4, space.
1, 2, 3, 4...
No, I didn't...
I didn't...
I don't know.
That was an accent.
Space.
1, 2, 3.
And then...
Just one there.
Right?
Okay.
So now we work backwards.
1.
Space.
1, 2, 3.
Wai.
One.
1, 2, 3, space.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Oh, does that mean this one could be?
Space.
One, two, three, four.
One, two, three.
Sensei Makana.
Makana.
I've played Pokemon Picross.
Oh yeah, I've played that one too, except...
Oh, you can't technically play it in... or... you can't play it anymore, right?
Nah.
Sad.
I
have it on the 3DS, yeah, yeah.
You can't get it...
Yeah, you can't download it anymore, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, there's hints!
Wait, what's the hints?
What's this do?
Wait, what did I just do?
What does this do?
Oh, it turns off the... these.
Oh, no, no, no.
Wait, what if I do this?
Will you tip?
Go back to game.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Check mistakes.
We're too good, baby.
We're too good.
Oh, no.
Nope.
Now I'll make a mistake.
Okay, so it can't be that.
So this has to be part of the four.
This has to be part of four.
Space.
One, two, three, four.
One, two, three.
Like that.
It has to be like that.
So three... somehow.
Space.
One, two, three, four...
Wait, so then, one, two, three, space.
One, two, three, four.
I got it.
And then we can get rid of all this area.
And we can get rid of all this area.
Which clears up this, this, this, this, this, this.
We can actually get rid of...
All this area.
Because then I want...
Oh wait, can we?
We're... 14.
14.
Oh wait, I don't think so.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Yeah, this is exactly.
Sit down.
Three, four, five, six.
No, no, no.
Okay, now we can do that.
One, two, three.
Four, five, six.
Okay, very good, very good.
Over there.
Four, six.
Seven.
One, two, three.
Four, five, six, seven.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
There we go.
Five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven.
Oh.
Um.
The...
We are good.
One, two,
three.
Um, um.
Um.
Um, um...
Um...
Um, um.
Oh.
Oh, oh!
Um,
um, um...
Um.
Um, um, um.
Oops.
Okay.
Craziness right now.
Absolute craziness.
There we go.
Well, we don't know exactly if this is connected or not, so...
I don't want to put it because one space...
This is eight, but this could also be the eight, you know?
One... Let's see.
We can do this area too.
Oh, I don't want to...
That down there?
There's more?
We could do it?
Really?
I don't believe you.
Don't lie to me.
No guarantee.
I get it.
I don't get it.
If...
I don't know.
I already explained it.
I would explain it again.
I already explained it at the beginning of the stream.
Sorry.
I already... Oh.
I'm allowed to help the column 18116.
You know the eight.
Oh, you're right.
It has to be this, right?
Yeah, you're right.
Because this is two.
Obviously, it can't be one-one.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Appreciate it.
Oh, well, I've...
Let's see.
This one, too.
What else can we do here?
There's still so much room.
This one makes sense because there's like a ten and eleven.
Let's see.
All right, one.
One.
Spice.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven.
One.
Space.
Oh, my God.
I have a gnat in my room.
Get out of my face.
I think it's just one square.
Yep.
It's just a one square.
I don't think it's Starry Night.
Somehow you guys were saying that.
I don't think so.
I really can't tell at all.
I can't tell at all what it would be.
I hope you're having a super peak cross day, me too.
Thank you when I can.
Thank you.
How?
Okay, we're gonna have to get rid of these for now.
I don't know what they want me to do here.
What do you see that I don't see?
Okay, five.
Space.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
One.
Wait, no, space.
One, space.
One, two, three.
Okay, so now we do one, two, three.
Space.
One.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Space.
Yeah, we can't do anything with the five.
Oh.
Okay.
I like how I'm like, usually when you place a new thing.
Like, you know, I got rid of the blue on here.
It would usually light up the blue here, but no.
It says, I'm...
No help for you.
But look at all the progress we've made in only 30 minutes.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
We're really putting the brain to work today, huh?
Space.
Okay, so.
Two, three.
One.
One, two, three.
One, two, three, four.
Five, six, seven.
Look, it's even...
Okay, yeah.
Oh, wait.
That's wrong.
There we go.
Like that.
Okay, let's try...
Let's try this one.
Because it's a big number.
One.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Didn't I do this one already?
One, two, three.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Oh, I didn't do that one.
Come on.
So, I think...
Let's see.
If I do eight here...
We wouldn't be able to fill in the rest.
So, the two, two, one, one...
Are most likely...
Yeah, okay.
So...
What's eleven?
Uh...
Four, five...
Yeah.
Okay, like that.
Like that.
Like...
Oh, I was right.
And like that.
Two.
Like that.
Okay.
My brain cells are dying.
Don't worry.
One, two, three, four, five, six...
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
I don't know what else they want me to do here.
If it's Picasso, then there's no guessing it.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
If this is like the nose...
And this is like an awkward eyeball...
Or this is a nose...
Oh gosh.
It could be Picasso.
Oh my gosh.
It could be...
It could be Picasso.
Oh wait.
One...
Two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
Space.
One, two, three.
One, two, three, four.
Space.
Ah.
Okay.
I don't know what they want me to do in this one.
In this row.
Space.
Yep.
This one too.
I'm so confused.
Seven.
One.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh.
Wait.
There's still more?
Oh maybe.
One, two.
No?
Then like that.
Wait.
Oh.
Maybe like this.
I have no idea what they want me to do here.
One.
Two.
Oh.
Just like that.
I'm silly.
There we go.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Woo.
Let's, let's.
Let's move away from this one for a bit.
It's confusing, right?
It's confusing me.
X here.
Okay.
So three.
Space.
One, two, three.
Wait.
I have a counter.
Eight.
Here.
Okay.
So now if we do one.
One, two, three.
One.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
What did it?
Huge.
Oh wait.
I'm wrong.
Sorry.
I thought, I thought three was the last one.
So I was like, oh, it can't be three.
Okay.
Huge.
Cause real.
So let's just say three.
Boom.
Space.
Nine, ten.
That's what I just added, right?
Three, four, five.
Six, seven, eight.
Nine, ten.
Come on.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Nine.
Okay.
12th column.
Oh gosh.
I can't count the columns.
That's too many columns.
There's too many.
I can't keep track of those numbers too.
One.
Space.
I feel like a deflating balloon right now.
I feel like a deflating balloon.
Oh wait, here.
And then here.
Oh my gosh.
Big.
Big, big, big.
Big development.
One.
Two.
Space.
One, two, three, space.
One, two, space.
One, two, three, four, five.
I don't know.
One, one.
Four.
Okay.
Big developments are happening.
11.
Yes.
Three.
Nine, ten, eleven.
Yes.
Okay, so here.
One space... Okay.
Yes.
Gosh, slowly but surely.
Slowly but surely.
We're making it out.
Let's see if... Okay.
Let's say this is two... One...
I know that I have to just figure out... Where the two needs to go and figure out... Okay.
Hold on.
So two space.
One, two, three.
See, it can't be the hot.
Can I give a super vague hint about painting?
About this painting?
Or... Because no.
I don't want a hint about it.
Oh, wait.
This is big.
We can get rid of all this.
Oh,
my...
Yeah.
Thanks for asking.
If you... If you could send it or not.
Thank you.
Or... But thank you also for the super chat.
Thank you so much.
Yes.
Sorry.
My brain is so focused.
I'm so focused right now.
11... 12... 13... 14... 15...
15... 15... 15... 15... 15... 15... 15... 15... 15... 15... 15... 16... 16... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 17... 18... 17... 17... 18... 17... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 18... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19... 19...
19 Well, maybe it could.
Oh, yeah, because it could be two, one, two, two.
Oh, wait, but there's this... Wait, wait.
Two, say that's the first two.
Two.
Ah, I don't know.
Clicky sound is so nice.
Can't keep my eyes on it for too long.
I gotta blink more.
My eyes are gonna dry.
Yeah, my ectoplasm is gonna be non-existent.
Oh, wait.
No, never mind.
I lied.
Ah...
Okay, the fatigue is starting to set in.
The fatigue is gonna... Wait.
Three.
Four.
Yes.
I won't reveal it's snake eating a...
A snake burger.
Oh, man.
That's what I thought it was.
Dang it, why didn't you just let me...
Get it.
I did choose a big one, and so I did... I wanna...
But, like, okay.
I can't not end on...
One of size that I've never done before, you know?
Like, that's just so exciting, no?
Oh...
Thirteen and fourteen of the time.
It's so exciting.
That's right.
To try a new P-cross.
Oh my gosh.
I can't tell at all what it is.
I don't know.
What if it's one that we don't know?
That would suck.
That would be no fun.
Wait.
Oh yeah.
It looks like a man.
With a hat on.
It looks like someone with a hat.
I think.
I think, I think, I think.
VOD Watchers...
Don't skip.
Don't even blink.
It'll be over before you know it.
VOD Watchers...
Still feels like Starry Night?
Where?
I don't think so.
Okay.
Watching at five times speed.
Is what the VGM sounds like.
I still don't also understand what they want me to do here.
It's crazy.
What do you want me to do here?
I can't tell if it's a two or a one.
Stop acting like you know everything game.
Stop acting like you know...
Wait, this is five.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Four, five, six, seven.
Hi, VOD Watchers.
VOD Watchers...
Back 45 minutes...
To the start of the puzzle.
46 minutes...
Actually.
This is definitely a guy standing.
This is a standing man emoji.
It's gotta be.
Okay.
Two.
There we go.
Three, three, one.
One, space.
One, two, three.
Space.
Okay.
I'm gonna check if I have any mistakes so far, you guys.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I see it.
Wait.
Not that many.
Easy fixes.
I'd say.
I don't know.
I feel like that was cheating.
I feel like...
That was kind of cheating.
But this thing is so busy...
Not busy.
It is pretty busy.
This thing is so big...
That...
It's fine.
Probably.
It's fine to check.
Hold on, let me do my throat spray.
Nasty.
Okay.
But this part...
We're really getting...
We're really starting to fill it out.
I think we'll get it sooner rather than later.
Trust everybody, trust.
We're going at a pretty good pace, I'd say.
Trust the process.
One, space.
Unless this is the wine...
Space.
I don't...
I don't trust myself...
To...
To touch it right now.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh, wait.
Just kidding.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Okay.
Five...
Six.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm being careful about my choices.
Feels like a fatigue check than anything else.
True.
I want to leave, but I can't have to...
What do you mean...
What do you mean you want to leave?
You want to leave.
I need to pee.
Okay.
Go...
Go pee.
It's not good to hold it in.
Don't worry, I won't solve it in the time that you go potty.
One, two, three, four, five.
Unless...
What if I like...
What if I super lock in...
I don't know.
Within that time...
Wouldn't that be so crazy?
You come back and it's completely solved.
Okay, now that...
Now that he's gone, I'm gonna look up a guide.
I'm just gonna look up what the picture looks like.
What if I...
Look at this guy's face!
I look up a guide and I fill it in really...
really fast.
And then I'm like, sorry.
Sorry, man.
I finished it.
That's so mean.
Okay, hold on.
I'm losing track.
I'm losing focus.
Okay.
Oh my god, we solved...
We solved that.
We solved this column.
And this column.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
We solved two columns.
Huge, huge, huge, huge.
Actually huge.
Wait, you could see this guy so clearly.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
It's mostly difficult trying to remember like...
How do I say?
Like keeping track of making sure...
Each...
piece...
I don't know how to describe it.
Like it's like...
Oh, I put a four here.
Put a four here.
And not accidentally putting a four here too.
You know what I mean?
That's...
That's what's so confusing for me.
It can be at least.
Okay.
Four, space.
One, two, three.
Oh, wow.
So this is four.
One, two, three.
Space.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
We're almost done with half of it.
We're almost done with half.
Oh, my gosh.
I think I'm leveling up my Picross skills...
tenfold today.
That sounds like something exactly I'd screw up.
Right?
It'd be so easy to.
It would be...
Okay.
Nevermind.
See, there's another one.
See, like...
What if I marked all this off?
Like that.
But I didn't notice that there was another one.
It would screw everything up.
It's so easy to screw stuff up here.
So, so easy.
Okay, so there's a two in here.
And then eight.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Yep.
Just like that.
I don't think it's American Gothic.
That's the one with the guy holding the pitchfork and the wife next to him, right?
Because I totally thought the same thing.
I 100% thought that it might be that one.
But then I was like...
But I'm pretty sure that guy is not wearing a hat.
And he has like the glasses on and stuff.
Yeah...
Actually, it's his daughter?!
Sorry, it...
Not...
That's his daughter?!
The wife is on the left.
He's on the right anyway.
Oh.
I see.
One, two...
This one's tough.
Toughy, toughy, tough.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Oh, huh.
Okay.
I still can't tell if...
This is a part of the ten?
Or if this is...
This is the...
I don't know.
I have to do the math eventually.
One, two, three, four, five...
See, that's not possible.
So...
Wait.
Ten.
See, okay.
This is what confuses me so much about this one.
So, look.
We could have one...
Ten...
Six...
Oh!
I thought that was four.
I already solved it,還有...
Why...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha ha...
Okay, wait.
Now...
Uh, shoot.
Okay, wait.
But then is this the ten?
Okay, all I know is that I can connect these.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I can connect those.
Why is this one...
This one is...
Scrumming up so bad.
This is the stick and rope.
And then this one...
Okay, hold on.
We can do this one too.
Because...
There's...
Like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I think so.
Hold on, I'm gonna double check.
Just wait a minute.
Oh, never mind.
I was so wrong.
Oh, I see.
I got...
I got him for the answer.
I got hand fed the answer.
I'm sorry.
I got spoon fed it.
Oh, I got spoon fed it.
No...
There.
I got old.
I got my...
I got my morning.
We got that.
4, 2.
Right?
2, 1, 2, 2.
Like that.
Okay.
Wait, did I just solve this one?
One, two, three, four.
Yeah, we did.
I think you made a mistake.
I did.
I messed up?
Wait, what did I do?
Go back.
Wait, wait, I messed up.
One, two... I see.
I... I... I... I stuck the three and the one.
I switched them in my head.
I'm a little... I can't do numbers well.
I messed up them in my head.
Just gotta connect the hat.
Yep.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, but then we can still do this.
Getting the nonogram dyslexia.
Okay, I'll tell you guys a secret.
Sometimes, I don't know the answer, but I can tell what it is in the picture, so I just connect the dots in the picture.
That's my...
...nodogram...
...tip.
That's my tip for you.
That's amazing.
Vibes based nonograms.
Pretty much...
One.
Oh, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Oh, one.
One.
Oh, oh.
And then right here.
Okay, okay, okay.
One, one, one.
Feel the solution.
Yeah.
Entirely vibes based, but it works.
It works.
Sometimes.
And sometimes, you didn't get it right at all.
Uh, one, two, three, four, space, one, two, three, four.
Guys, we're... We're only... Okay, some people were saying this took them, like, so many hours.
But...
I'm getting it.
Not so bad.
How long have I been streaming, though?
Three hours.
It's okay.
I have the next two days off.
It's all good.
It's all good, baby.
Okay.
Like that.
I'm gonna hear this music in my dreams.
It's Toby Fox.
It looks like maybe he's holding something.
It looks like... This looks like a snake with a top hat.
And this looks like Homestar Runner.
They're about to kiss.
Don't ever ask me what I see in the clouds.
Wait, what else can I do here?
I wonder what she sees in the clouds.
Which is worse to get stuck in your head, though?
This or Meow Tower?
Oh, actually, I never think about the Meow Tower track.
Because...
I don't play it with music on, usually.
So I never think about it.
Oh, this row is still a mystery to me.
Okay, hold on.
This row maybe is...
I don't want to touch it yet.
I don't want to take big risks.
One.
I think we can do this one.
One, two, three.
Space.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
I don't want to...
Eight.
This one too.
One.
One, two, three.
Space.
Maybe...
I think I just don't know this painting.
I don't know.
I love how...
This guy is staring at me.
Staring me down.
It's kind of freaky.
It's kind of freaking me out.
She's gonna...
I don't like it.
Oh, wait.
I can solve this one.
Nice.
We solved this mystery.
Oh, wait.
Can I...
Two, one...
Oh.
I could solve it this whole time.
I didn't notice.
I didn't even notice.
Okay.
He's watching the stream with us.
Stream...
Sniper.
The column was done for a while.
It's so hard to tell sometimes.
It's hard to tell sometimes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Sorry.
I thought it was two twos.
Two twos.
Three.
Okay.
So, one somewhere.
And then one.
Okay.
Oh, yo, yo, yo.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, that's that.
Space.
Wait.
One, two, three, four, five.
Yeah.
Space.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
1, 2, 3, 4, space.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Why am I not using the counter?
Okay.
It's not very well known in the US popular culture.
It's a pride and joy of an insert museum here.
Oh, it gets its own wall and everything?
Really?
Is he riding a horse?
I'm trying to
figure out which one I want to go for right now.
Maybe this?
Oh.
It looks like his hands are up.
Yeah, maybe.
It belongs in a museum.
Clearly.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
I don't know why I didn't do that sooner.
Okay, so three...
We'll just do space like that.
Uh...
One...
Space...
One, two, three...
One, two, three, four...
Space...
Five, six, seven...
Ah...
This is art.
It is art.
Raiden, are you enjoying...
Are you enjoying this?
One...
Space...
One, two, three, four...
Hmm...
Maybe?
I'm gonna check if that's right or not.
One, two, three, four...
Holy...
We got it.
So far, so good.
If this is a horse...
Okay, all I see is it's...
Okay, I see ears like this.
I see a nose like Brian Griffin.
And I see a little dot pixel eye.
It looks so stupid.
Like it's all...
It's all I see...
At the moment.
I know I...
It says I can do this role, but...
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Okay, so this...
Like that...
I think...
Okay...
I'm so nervous.
You're done with the 4, 1, 1, 1, 8 column.
I don't even see that.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
One, two...
Space...
Wait, space.
Let's just say one.
I'm so tired.
I don't think I will play Miao Tower tonight.
I think I've had my fill.
She didn't say anything really exciting.
When I completed that one, it makes...
It feels bad, man.
It feels bad.
Please get excited once I complete a column.
Every time, please.
Oh.
I don't think I finished it.
That's why...
I think that's why.
Because I didn't technically finish it.
Oh.
Now I feel better.
Now I feel validated.
Okay, so...
4...
1...
Wait.
What row am I at?
4...
1...
2...
Wait, I think we finished this one also.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
The end is nigh.
The end is near.
For half the painting.
Oh
my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
We really completed like...
Exactly...
Like half of it.
Oh my god.
All the pieces are falling into place now.
Hehehehe.
Oh my god.
Okay.
So this would be one.
Most likely.
One...
Yes.
Wait, and this one too.
That's great.
Does PCOS get easier the more you solve?
Oh yeah.
Because eventually...
You'll...
Especially like with...
Like...
How do I say?
You'll start to recognize patterns.
And you'll be able to like...
Be a lot faster.
Because you can be like...
Oh, if I see...
4, 2, 4, 2, 1, 2.
I know where to put...
This, this, this, this, this, this, this.
You know?
And then yeah.
You'll rule out possibilities.
And it gets smaller, and smaller, and smaller, and smaller.
And eventually you complete it.
Yeah, assuming you haven't made any mistakes.
Yeah.
I'm kind of glad this has a little checker.
Not gonna lie.
Makes me feel at ease.
2, space.
Yeah, okay.
Wait, so then...
2, space.
6, space.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
There we go.
Like that.
Like this.
Like...
2...
Spares.
No, not yet.
What?
Oh, yeah.
That's...
It's grayed out.
I wonder what Nancy Drew would do.
She would...
She would probably...
Accept her fate and...
Drown in the...
In the onsen.
At the ryokan.
She would accept her fate.
Naruhodo.
Word.
Let's see.
What do you mean I can do something here?
I don't know.
Look at this one.
We haven't even put a single thing in some of these...
Rows or columns.
That's crazy.
Right?
The ones that we haven't even touched.
That's...
That's scary.
I think I'm done with the soundtrack.
I really liked it at first.
Can I change the song?
How do I...
How do I change the music?
How
do I change the music?
Oh...
Oh, whoa, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Uh, don't go...
Freedom.
Let's listen to...
This is what I always put on.
There is an option to change the song.
Oh, no kidding?
Oh, it probably changes...
It changes depending on... you know how it changes when you go to a different part of the museum?
It probably is like, if you want to change it to any of those songs.
But, I want to save those for when I hear them for the first time.
So, it's okay.
So, only two ones can fit in here.
So, let's just say one, space, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Has to be like that.
Right?
Okay, hold on.
Exactly.
I was right!
I knew I was right.
I was just testing you guys.
Why is it still so difficult?
If I do five, space...
So, it's not possible.
But, it could still be like space here.
Oh my gosh.
This area sucks.
So, let's just fill in these.
Because we know it's got to be that, at least.
I turn 11.
What if I start from down here, it goes to 11.
Then, how do you know?
Help the final artist, NSFW.
This kind of looks like a boob with a nipple.
It's nice and round.
In Minecraft.
Come on, come on.
Let's see.
6, 7, 8.
1, 2, 3.
Space.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So, for the 2, 1, 2, 1.
If the field is in box...
Wait.
Must be X under.
What?
For 2, 1, 2, 1.
If the field in box is 1...
It's X on both sides.
If it's 2, there must be...
Separated from the...
Oh!
I get it.
Therefore, it must be an X under.
Like she said.
That was not helpful.
Actually, it was quite helpful.
Once I...
Once I re-read it.
Only the bottom is guaranteed...
Yes!
So, the reason I left it alone is because I was like...
Oh, what if it's 2?
But you're so right.
I didn't even think about...
It would have to be like 2...
X, 1.
Or if it's 1, it's X here.
Thank you.
Art is just whatever you interpret it to be, after all.
I'm gonna become an artist...
That only does half paintings.
So that this P-Cross puzzle would be done by now.
It would be over.
Thank God, I'm not the streamer.
What do you mean by that?
Does this go to...
No.
Okay.
So now we can do this.
Like that.
Okay.
How we feeling, y'all?
How we feeling?
Good.
Wow, thank you so much for both.
Thank you.
But those would still be full P-Cross puzzles.
Well, no.
I would leave it like this.
This is how it would look.
Brian Griffin.
Well, not so much anymore.
Minecraft boom.
Aren't there like not safe for work mods for Minecraft?
What does that entail?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
You know all about them then.
Lots.
You guys are pros.
The internet exists.
Yeah.
I just like...
I just...
You know, I've only heard of it.
I don't...
I'm like, what?
What do you do in the...
Okay, so this can't be...
Wait.
I lied.
She's so cute when she does that.
Okay, yes.
Rewind.
I misread it as the two.
As this two.
Three.
One.
Two.
Wait a second.
Would it not be that?
Yeah.
Three, one, one...
Two.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I only know the giant bunny Toki mod.
I need that.
How do we come to this subject?
Oh.
Because this kind of looked like a Minecraft boom.
I see a cowboy holding a baby.
And an alien creature with one eye kind of looks like a Pokemon unknown gazing upon their child.
Not seeing it.
Oh my gosh.
Have some whimsy.
Whimsy.
Have some whimsy in your life.
I'm dead and I'm whimsy.
Wow, you got it.
No.
Don't lie to me.
Serious man in hat takes Etina on date.
No.
She's not allowed to date.
It'll break her parole.
I think we can do this.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
We're running out of blue.
How are we back to blue here?
What else can I do?
Okay, so this has to be four.
Yeah, yeah.
One, two, three, four.
Okay, this like that.
Five.
Okay.
And then this is...
Narn.
Okay, we're back in business.
Maybe.
A little bit.
Okay, we made some progress.
Okay.
And I'm off topic.
I'm snacking on some hot mustard Doritos.
And they're surprisingly good.
You should try them if you find them in your area.
Are they spicy?
I also hate the taste of mustard.
The 2-1-2-1 needs the same X as the 2-1 column.
This?
Huh?
Nah, I don't like mustard.
I've always hated it ever since I was a kid.
Hold
on.
Hold on.
I'm gonna check.
Okay, good.
I was scared for a second.
Okay, we can do this.
And we can do this.
Okay.
Got rid of that, at least.
Okay, let's go.
I just...
I'm waiting.
Wait a second.
What?
I guess so?
What...?
Oh, I see.
I think you...you mean like this, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got you.
I got you, I got you.
Okay.
Now, this is...gotta be...two.
And then this has got to be four.
Raiden seems to agree with the move.
You can put an X.
Yeah, I did.
Same for the two, one, two, one.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, what?
Yes.
Two, one.
Two, three.
Okay, I like that.
And then two...these are the twos.
Okay, so two, one.
There we go.
I'll get in there.
I can't tell what this...what the right side is, though.
It's taking shape, but into...what?
Into what?
I don't know yet.
Here.
Maybe.
It says we know, but I don't know.
It says we know, but don't trust it.
Okay.
It says we don't know, but we don't know.
We don't know.
Don't trust it.
Just don't trust it.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I thought that was a...a...a cross...out.
And I was like, about to...I was about to crash out.
I was about to be like, where did I make a mistake?
I could not...no!
Okay, so this can be like that.
We are so close.
Holy cow.
Maybe it will take me two hours.
In the end, I was bragging about how fast I was going.
That's gonna take me two hours also.
I was like, oh, yeah.
Please, no.
I've what?
It's 30 more minutes until two hours.
What I feel like is funny is because I feel like...
I don't have so much left.
Because I don't have so many blue left.
But I actually do have a lot left.
Because...
Oh, wait.
We can't complete this one.
Because there's still so many white.
You know what I mean?
Something seems incorrect.
You are the one incorrect.
I think this is probably like this.
Because it can't be...
Yeah, because there's three ones left.
So it can't be...
Can't be.
It can't be.
Okay.
Sorry.
What?
The two, five...
Two, two columns does it add up?
I don't know what to tell you.
It doesn't...
It said I didn't make any mistakes.
But also, yes, it does.
Five.
And then two and two.
Or this could be two.
This could be the five.
Two.
Okay.
I still don't know quite that one.
And two, three.
Oh.
Okay.
We can get that one.
And we can get that one.
Very nice.
And three.
And two.
Three.
One.
And two.
Okay.
I lost track of it.
Me eyes hurt.
We're almost there.
We just got...
We're so close to the finish line.
Don't give up on me now.
Okay, this is a two.
Somehow.
I'm not quite sure yet.
Rembrandt's Night Watch.
Oh.
I don't think that has been guessed.
Bottom blue line, you got a hint for the three.
Oh, yeah.
Well, no, I don't.
Because I can't...
Because it's...
It's six.
So it's like one, two, three.
Or one, two, three.
Like...
If it were five, I would be able to put something in the middle.
But...
I cannot.
Wait.
One, three...
Oh, this one.
You can fill in the three and the ten.
Here?
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
Let's see.
Two.
This could be two.
Two,
two, two.
Come on, come on.
And then this... goes like that.
And then this... like that.
Ah, my eyes.
Holy cannoli.
Oh, and then like that.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We can get this three.
Which means we can get this one.
Then we can get rid of this.
So we can put this down.
One, two, three, four.
Like that.
Five.
This.
One.
Like that.
I can't tell what the right side is at all.
I mean, we still have a lot to go.
I don't want to say that.
I'm in denial.
Okay, this is the two.
Which means we can do that.
Which means we can put in the three.
Which means this is the two.
Which means two.
And another column or row down.
Okay.
It's a creature.
Whatever it is.
It's some sort of creature.
Okay, we just need the three there.
And we can get...
One of the twos.
Well, this might not...
This might be a two.
It might be a one.
Because we still have this open as well.
Which is why we don't touch it.
But this is a two.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
And then there's...
Two.
Okay.
Famous painting.
Dude in hat with creature.
Oh, I saw that at the Louvre.
True story.
Real, real story.
This one is so evil.
Why does it have to be exactly four and exactly seven?
And then also exactly four right here.
How am I supposed to know?
Like...
It's so evil.
Absolutely...
Diverse.
Huh.
Just let me know when this BGM gets annoying too.
But it should be okay.
I don't think we have...
We don't have so much longer.
Honestly, this is just my normal...
Like, after stream routine.
So...
I would just be playing...
MeowTower...
Uh...
Nonograms...
After this anyway.
So it doesn't even feel like I'm streaming right now.
To me, I'm just...
I'm just so chill.
I'm so chill right now.
So chill.
I'm not even here.
Glad you're comfy.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I kind of got...
TikTok shop influence.
But I didn't buy it off the TikTok shop.
Oh, shoot.
I think I had a meeting.
Are they yelling at me?
Oops.
Oh, no.
I have it in 30 minutes.
Okay, good.
I got it wrong on the calendar.
Okay.
Anyway.
Okay, I have 30 minutes to solve this.
We could solve in 30.
Probably.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
What was I saying?
Okay.
Uh...
I didn't even notice.
Nine.
I don't know.
We can do that.
I don't remember what I was saying, though.
I don't remember.
Oh, you bought something because of TikTok.
Thank you.
Um, I didn't...
I...
Okay, so it's a chair.
So when I sit in my chair, I'm always like crisscross applesauce.
Or I'm sitting on my knees.
Or I'm like...
I'm all over the place.
And I found a chair that's made for that.
And...
I...
I've got it.
I'm gonna see if I like it.
Hopefully.
Otherwise, I just return it, but...
Yattel.
Mm-hmm.
But I was like...
Dang.
This is like made for me.
You got influenced.
I did.
Hopefully...
Hopefully it works well.
Try not to give exact answers, please.
Thank you.
I know you're just trying to help.
But I also want to solve it myself.
But thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, shoot.
We don't know if it's a one or the two.
Oh, my golly.
Okay.
But this is...
Got to be the two.
The one's here.
The two's here.
One...
Is that six?
Yes.
Do I deceive?
I probably would deceive...
After so long of staring at this.
Two...
One...
Two.
Okay, I'm checking.
No mistakes found.
And whatever the heck...
I still can't tell what it is at all.
I guess I...
Just don't know what the painting is.
There's...
I...
I feel like I just don't know what it is.
Okay, here.
This is eight, right?
Yes, okay.
Ten in the bottom right.
Wake.
Is that the dude's hand?
I can't tell.
It's going to be insane once we actually see what this actual painting is.
Because I can't tell at all what it is.
I can't tell.
It's a mystery.
One, two, three, four.
Three.
One.
One, one.
Yatta!
Yatta indeed, Raden.
Yatta indeed.
Raden.
How close are we?
How close is the finish line?
Please.なるほど.
Please.
Just tell me... Give me any sort of sign.
I think it's got to be like that.
I think...
Okay, hold on.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I was right.
I was just trying to make sure I don't need to backtrack, you know?
Okay.
So close.
Just count how many white squares you got left.
Right?
Still don't know this one.
The end is near.
Yeah.
I can't count anymore.
I've lost all...
all functions.
I've lost everything.
Wait, two.
Wait, I was looking at the wrong column.
Oh my gosh.
I've done that so many times before though.
Where I'm looking at the wrong column and I accidentally put some...
Luckily, they have, like, the...
It's much more manageable here.
But it's still tricky sometimes.
We're almost there!
We're almost there.
Yes.
Eat it!
Okay.
Wait, is that five?
One, two, one.
Can't count.
Yes.
Okay.
What is it?
Is it his hand?
Oh, like, his arm extending out?
Creepy.
Three, one, three...
Four...
So bright.
Unlock them.
Wait, did I just mess that up?
I can't tell.
I can't
tell.
Oh, wait.
Maybe it's a girl looking at him.
Like, this is the hair.
And this is her hat.
And, like, she's got, like, a...
Scarf looking thing on here.
She's like...
It looks like she's looking at him.
I think...
I think, I think, I think, I think...
I had a thought.
Music.
Maybe...
Wait, is this ten?
Yes.
So, two...
Hey, I just finished another road, Raden.
Please, tell me... that you're proud of me.
Tell me that you're proud of me, please.
Oh, wait.
We can finish this row, too.
Are you good on time?
Yep.
I'm genuinely worried about some of your viewers' ability to absorb visual information.
They say...
Like stream or like chat.
Or chat reflects the stream.
What are you trying to say, huh?
What are we...
What are we trying to say here?
I like how it...
Kind of shows you...
What ones that you still need to fill out.
But like...
I don't know.
This system is very intuitive.
It's really nice.
Five, six.
Like see?
It shows here that I've filled out the other things.
But I still need to do the two.
You know?
Like that.
It's really nice.
So then if I do this...
I've already filled out the other stuff.
I just have to...
Do like that.
It's kind of nice.
What else we got?
Guys, the end is near.
What am I missing?
Oh, here.
Is this it?
Is this the last one?
Whoever guessed the night watch?
You got it.
What?
I
thought it was a cow of mine.
I thought it was a cow of mine.
Oh, Rembrandt.
Wow...
Wow!
This is the second one.
Thank you!
This is the first sentence.
This is called Rembrandt Lighting.
It is used to be used to play and play, and it is used to be used to play.
Oh...
I'm sub two hours, baby.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
It's cut off your name, not...
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you.
All right, so I'm finishing the night watch.
I'm disappointed.
To not see cowboys embracing each other, but...
I'm happy to see you beat it.
Yeah.
Oh my goodness.
Well, I did two more hours than I expected to.
For the stream.
One last puzzle.
Thank you so much for the...
For the...
Who's the one?
Huh.
Yes.
But...
Nice.
GG, everybody.
Thank you for the help with this last one.
And with the other ones as well.
We did...
We made a great team.
Be proud of yourselves.
We solved it together.
16 people crowdfunded the commission for it.
You could see an ultra-high zoom version online.
Commission?
Really like the fan game culture that sprung up around VTubers.
Me too.
Oh, okay.
Thank you guys for the stream.
What's your song?
Thank you so much for the tech gifted.
I'm gonna...
Spray my throat real quick.
Let's go.
One more.
Maybe if it's...
If it's five by five.
Oh, it's five by five.
Otumito, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Have a good day.
And I will see you...
When I see you next.
Otumito.
Which I stream in...
Today, so...
I can rest some...
My voice some more.
I need it after this.
Bye-bye.
Iってらっしゃい.
Rebel guitarist.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Good kid.
Stop riding.
I'm done.
I'm leaving.
Bye-bye.